there is no doubt that on a global level
the most famous Sufi in the world or the
person that most people associate with
Sufism is the Persian Mystic and poet
jalala Deen Rumi his poetry has been
translated into numerous languages and
he has been one of the best selling
poets in all of North America and Europe
even 800 years after he lived his verses
include themes of love and heartbreak
entertaining stories and profound
insights that touch people worldwide
even today
at the same time Rumi is also a greatly
misunderstood figure
many people know that he was a so-called
Sufi that he belonged to the tradition
known as Sufism and this is true but
what does this actually mean
fewer still are aware of the fact that
he was a devoted Muslim whose poetry is
infused with and can really only be
properly understood through the context
of his Islamic intellectual framework a
lot of the Poetry of Rumi that has
become so famous through you know quotes
on Instagram post or all over the
Internet are often based on questionable
translations that will remove all the
Islamic context and Islamic references
and his poetry and a lot of the quotes
that we see on on the internet also just
upright false they're not by Rumi at all
but that isn't to say that roommate
doesn't have Universal appeal which he
certainly does his works are incredibly
beautiful regardless of your background
but we do ourselves a disservice when we
neglect to understand the actual context
in which he writes the symbolism that he
uses and what his colorful words are
actually pointing to on a broader level
Rumi is one of the most popular and
influential Sufi writers in history even
in the Islamic world so let's take a few
minutes to try to get to know this giant
of mystical and Persian literature who
was Rumi really what was the historical
context in which he lived and worked and
how can we get a better and more nuanced
understanding of his philosophy and his
his world view so that we can better
appreciate the literary masterpieces
that he composed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
was born in the year 1207 in the region
known as Horizon
his nispah or the title El belgi seems
to indicate that he was from the city of
belch in particular
and while it is true that his father and
family had a connection with the city of
belch it seems possible that Rumi
himself was born and spent his first
years in a city called Vach in modern
Tajikistan where his parents resided for
a couple of years
this region was part of the larger
Persian cultural sphere and Rumi and his
family Thus Spoke Persian as their
native language and took part in that
cultural context you could say
his father Baha Adin valad was a
religious scholar of relative Renown and
seems to have worked essentially as a
preacher and teacher of some of the
religious Sciences such as firk or
Islamic jurisprudence
Baha Deen and his family followed the
hanafi school of Islamic law a tradition
that his son Rumi would also inherit
later on this together with the Shafi
School were the most prominent in this
region at the time and the hanafi school
is today the largest of all the four
major schools as well as often being
considered the most quote unquote
liberal from his surviving writing such
as the Mahadev as well as from secondary
accounts it also becomes clear that baja
Deen was a Mystic involved with Sufism
and having ecstatic Visionary
experiences of the Divine
and on account of both of these aspects
of his career being a teacher of
exoteric Sciences but also a Sufi Sheikh
of sorts he had a modest group of
followers or students that often
accompanied him
this already shows that one common
narrative about Rumi's life is not
entirely accurate it's often claimed
that Rumi was an entirely
exoterically oriented formalistic Muslim
scholar until he met Shem satabrizi
after which point he becomes an ecstatic
Mystic like a complete 180 turnaround
this was not the case Rumi was very much
aware of mysticism and Sufism it was all
around him as he grew up his father was
a Mystic all the kind of people around
him were sufis and Mystics he would have
been deeply immersed at least on a
surface level
that that doesn't make sense it would
have been deeply involved or deeply
aware of the Sufi tradition as it was
all around him even in his own family so
this is important remember already one
of those common misconceptions about
Rumi that we have to dispel in any case
the family including the young jalaladin
seems to have eventually moved to
Samarkand where bahayadin ran into some
trouble as he would criticize and kind
of get into a beef with the ruling Elite
for being morally and religiously
corrupt and only a few years later they
made another an even more significant
move this time leaving the East for good
probably around the year 1217 when
jalaladin would have been around 10
years old they left Samarkand and
Horizon to travel to the west and never
to return
there are various theories and accounts
as to why they made this sudden move a
popular version is that baja Deen and
his family saw the looming threat of the
Mongol armies that were getting closer
and closer and chose to leave before
that would become
an issue
this is possible but the Mongol invasion
was still a few years away and it would
have been hard to know beforehand that
such an invasion was in fact going to
happen
so another theory is that Deen's
increasingly bad relationship with the
ruling Shah Dynasty actually forced him
to leave due to these political
circumstances it's hard to say exactly
what happened but what we do know for
sure is that parts of his family
including jalaladin and a group of
followers did indeed leave the region to
travel to the Islamic heartlands in the
West
they visited Bhagavad for a while they
went on a pilgrimage to Mecca to perform
the the Hajj one of the pillars of the
Islamic religion they might have stayed
in Syria for a while and even settled
for a couple of years in a city called
larende from around the year 1221.
it's here that jalaladin came of age got
married and had his first children
including Sultan valad who would take
over after his father's death and was
instrumental in the founding of the
melody order but it was in another place
that the family and of course Rumi would
find their permanent home when possibly
on the invitation of the seljuk ruler
Allah they moved to the city of Konya in
what is today turkey this is possibly in
the year 1228.
this was a good place to be being a
major political and cultural center of
the seljuk Empire and it allowed
baha'adin to establish himself as a
pretty prominent religious Authority and
teacher
now when we read the hegeographies about
murumi and his life his father bahadin
is portrayed as a world-renowned
religious scholar the quote King of the
ulama who was sought by people from all
over the Islamic world for his expertise
and questions of hanafi law among other
things
the historical record does not really
support this idea though and is likely
an exaggeration after the fact
he was a religious authority to be sure
he had a group of followers and he
managed to become quite popular and
relatively prominent in cornea in the
last years of his life but probably
nowhere near the kind of portrayal and
Renown that we find in the hagiographies
he taught in a prominent madrasa in
Konya and had the authority to issue
fatwas or legal opinions on matters of
Law and religion but one of the reasons
that they settled in Konya rather than
in one of the more major cities
associated with Islamic scholarships
such as Baghdad Damascus and Cairo is
probably that he couldn't really get any
employment there
this would have required a much more
accomplished and established renowned
person
Konya on the other hand was more on the
borders of the Islamic empire
it was a significant center of the
seljuk Empire but nothing like Baghdad
in terms of scholarship Anatolia was a
place that had recently been conquered
and much of the population were either
still non-muslims altogether or recently
converted Muslims that didn't know much
about the details of its practices and
ideas
this in other words was a great place
for someone like Baha Adin to be in
order to teach religion in a place where
the demand was high especially since he
was also a Mystic and Incorporated the
Sufi aspects into his religious teaching
and preaching something that was rather
popular and sought after in that region
at the time
as we all know this would also be a good
place for his son to only a few years
later become an even more prominent
scholar and and figure than his father
ever was and it is indeed because of his
association with with Konya and in this
larger region that Rumi is known as Rumi
in the Islamic world it was either known
as
this region that he was from originally
or simply as Maulana which means our
master mevlana in Turkish
there is some early references to him
being given the name or being referred
to by the name mawlana Rumi and why is
this where does this name come from
because it does have its origins in the
Islamic tradition and in the medley
order that followed him even though it
wasn't as common as it is today and it
is essentially because he was associated
with this region cornea and Anatolia
this region was known as room
which means Rome basically because this
place had been ruled by the Byzantine
Empire the Eastern Roman Empire so this
was considered uh the you know part of
the wider region of Rome or Rome so
jalaladin Rumi essentially means
jalaladin the Roman right or the one
from Rome or from Rome which is really
interesting
valad the father of jalaladin Rumi
unfortunately passed away only about two
years after they arrived in Konya either
in 12 30 or 12 31. himself would have
been around 25 years old at this point
and while apparently already a respected
teacher and preacher of sorts he was not
old enough to take over all of his
father's previous responsibilities
but just in time one of Baha adin's
older close students from the balc
region arrived in Konya
this was
at this point an ecstatic Sufi master
and family friend who took jalaladin
under his wing
for the remainder of burhanadin's Life
Rumi would remain his student and
considered him his Sheikh
purana Deen first sent Rumi to Syria to
properly study the exoteric religious
scientists like law and theology with
renowned teachers there
Rumi would spend the majority of the
1230s in Syria in places like Aleppo and
Damascus a place that of course had many
significant figures both Scholars and
Mystics living there at the time
once he returned to Konya he was a
significantly learned scholar surpassing
even his father in religious knowledge
and it was at this point that borhana
Dean started to teach Rumi the mystical
Sufi path
again Rumi would have of course been
surrounded by a Sufism throughout his
life since his father was a yusufi
Sheikh and he was in the know so to say
in various ways but it was under but
Hannah Dean that he started traveling on
the Sufi path properly over a number of
years eventually becoming an
accomplished Master himself
he would go on several spiritual
Retreats he would fast for long periods
of time and all the other practices
associated with Sufi training about a
decade after he arrived but Hannah Dean
eventually passed away around the year
1241 but at that point Rumi's training
was already complete and he would thus
start his career properly as an
increasingly famous and renowned scholar
and Mystic
Rumi was an expert in hanafi Islamic law
and he would give fatwas or legal
opinions on different matters he would
also teach other students and he gained
a very favorable reputation
combining an expertise in exoteric
religious Sciences as well as his role
as a Sufi master and Sheikh Rumi
eventually surpassed his father in
reputation and renown
just like his father he was a fantastic
preacher and was very popular among the
common people
both himself and other people at the
time agreed that Rumi was especially
skilled at attracting people of
different religious backgrounds
particularly Christians for some reason
and through his preaching and teaching
he would often lead them to convert to
Islam
in other words Rumi was essentially on
top of the world at this time he was one
of the most renowned and popular
scholars in Konya both as a teacher of
Islamic law and and so on and also as a
Sufi Sheikh and Mystic who was known for
performing Miracles and all these self
self negating and renunciate practices
so again this idea of rumias as a
totally exoteric
you know formalistic Muslim scholar that
then suddenly turns into a Mystic is not
entirely accurate but there is a point
to be made that he was certainly at this
time a sort of public figure someone who
was known as a scholar
a man of book learning and and and and
worldly religious knowledge so to say
then as most of us know something
happens
something that would turn jalaladin from
Balch into Rumi as we know him
that something was a man called
shamsadin atabrizi who arrived in Konya
in November 1244 and when turned room is
life upside down
there are many different accounts of
their first meeting each one of course
more dramatic than the next Shams
apparently settled in a local Inn for
Rice sellers when he arrived in Konya
and an early account of their meeting
takes place in a pavilion right outside
this Inn as Rumi and his companions were
passing by one day
in most accounts Shams asks a question
of Rumi usually involving the famous
early Sufi by Asia the bistami Shams
himself in his surviving writings called
the makalat describe their meeting like
this quote
the first thing I spoke about with him
was this how is it that abuyazid did not
need to follow the example of the
prophet and did not say glory be to thee
or we worship thee
and Rumi completely understood the full
implications of the problem and where it
came from and where it was leading to
made him inebriated on account of his
purity of spirit for his Spirit was pure
and cleansed and it shun within him I
realized the sweetness of this question
from his inebriation though I had
previously been unaware of its sweetness
in one of the more common versions Shams
approaches Rumi as as he is walking by
and he asks him a very
um
interesting question a very radical
question you could say he says who is
the better Mystic and who is the better
at Sage
or the Prophet Muhammad
which obviously is a very loaded
question a very
controversial question
and and and of course consciously so
this is this is the whole point probably
a room is a student or followers the
ones around him would have been shocked
by this question but Rumi is intrigued
and he actually answers the question he
says
he says that the prophet Muhammad is is
the superior Mystic or the superior man
uh
shams
then replies back and he says how come
then
exclaimed subhani by this famous
ecstatic utterance by bastami which
means glory be to me he said to have
said this in a sort of ecstatic moment
of annihilation in God he said subhani
glory be to me how come bistami says
that whereas Muhammad
says glory be to thee he speaks of God
and in second person
uh
so how come that Muhammad is the
superior
person
and then which is a good point of course
Rumi then answers something to the
effect that bistami was in fact Limited
in his understanding and had
misconstrued that limit as having
actually reached God whereas Muhammad
who had gone much further on the path
had realized that this journey and this
this this way to God was was eternal and
much longer and thus he
spoke about God in a different way with
and then the second person rather than
the first person so this is a higher
station than bistami it's a really
fascinating encounter and it it had an
incredibly strong impact on both Rumi
and Shams it becomes the starting point
for a very significant and long
spiritual relationship indeed in some
ways this meeting between Rumi and Shams
is one of the most significant moments
in religious and literary history as two
spiritual Giants meet for the first time
and begin a relationship that would lead
to some of the greatest poetry in
history as well as of course having
major effects on the future of not only
Sufism and Islam but the entire Islamic
world and Beyond
this is one of the great love stories of
the world not necessarily romantic or
physical love but a spiritual one
Rumi and Shams are inseparable from this
moment on
some Reports say that they would shut
themselves into a room for weeks or
months in deep spiritual discussion
Rumi goes from being a public scholar
and teacher to a kind of recluse
from a man of books and conceptual
learning to an ecstatic and intoxicated
Mystic
Rumi is reported by shamstrev said quote
since I've become acquainted with you
these books have become lifeless in my
eyes
it is after the arrival of Shams that
the roomy discovers the power of music
as a spiritual practice in the form
known as Sama a Sufi practice that stem
backed many centuries
Shams Rumi and his disciples would hold
such rituals of audition regularly and
it became a significant aspect of his
mysticism
Rumi's love for music as a spiritual
practice is widely known and famous and
he would often move to the music in a
kind of worlding and meditative motion
it often said it was spin around with
his arms extended The Scholar Franklin D
Lewis says quote Sama was an activity
for the true men of God which liberated
Rumi from the austere ways of
self-renunciation and gave him a joyous
vehicle for expressing his mystical
rapture
it even seems that Rumi was himself a
musician and that he played the rabab a
string instrument that is playing with a
bow that still survives today actually
he mentions that above in many of his
poems in a loving way and his son Sultan
balad even wrote a poem called the rabab
name which mirrors Rumi's own the song
of the read in a really interesting kind
of way and this love of music and the
particular kind of sama and dance that
Rumi shems and the disciples would
perform was to have a great effect on
the medley order later on too it is also
in this period that Rumi very
significantly starts to compose poetry
for the first time
in many ways the reason Rumi wrote
poetry was to relay the teachings of
shems
as we saw earlier Rumi was exceptionally
skilled at communicating with the Common
People whereas shem's ecstatic teachings
were hard for people to grasp so urumi
saw his mission as one where he would
use those oratorian literary skills to
convey the truths of shems to be the
Moon that reflected the light of the Sun
so to say
Rumi says in a poem quote shamsi tabris
through your son we shine just like the
Moon
this all being a pun on the fact that
the name Shams in Arabic literally means
Sun
s himself says quote this mawlana is
like Moonlight the eye cannot take in
the son of my being but he can't take in
the Moon
the extreme brightness of the Rays make
the eye unable to tolerate the Sun
the moon cannot reach the sun unless the
Sun reaches out to the Moon
indeed the great Divan of Rumi or his
collection of poems was given the title
Divani shems or Divan of shem's tabrizi
that is the Divine of shems as the whole
work is dedicated to this master and
often takes on his poetic Persona the
relationship between Rumi and shems is
really unique and interesting
in many ways Rumi took on shem's as his
master a Sheikh who guided him to full
absorption in God unto the utmost
Stations of the mystical path
but at the same time Rumi was already
himself a Sufi Master when the two met
and Sham seems to have also learned a
lot from Rumi so in other words they
were kind of some kind of spiritual
Companions of a sword who lifted each
other up to the heights of spiritual
attainment
quote my thoughts and Reflections
inspired by you as though I were your
phrases and expression
but who was this Shams that had such a
great impact on Rumi
as his name suggests he was from the
city of tabaris in what is today Iran
but up until a few decades ago this was
basically all that we knew all the the
information we have are from the
writings of Rumi and his disciples which
basically limits us to the period after
his arrival in Konya and we knew very
little about his life and who he was
before that
that is until only a few decades ago
when the actual writings of Shams was
discovered which of course gives us a
much broader and better picture of who
he was
now the common Narrative of Shams even
today with all this information is that
he was some sort of just wandering
dervish which he was of course but in in
the sense that he was sort of illiterate
um just
that walked around with with nothing but
a prayer mat and a flute and then was
possibly illiterate and had reached
illumination by some sort of inspiration
and experience
um but when we read his actual works it
becomes clear that while this vision
isn't entirely wrong it's not the whole
picture either because Shams seems to
have been a rather well-educated man
just like Rumi he would have studied the
Islamic Sciences he was an expert in
Islamic law although in this case he was
a Shafi rather than a hanafi lag Rumi
but still he would have studied
deeply the religious Sciences of Islam
and literature he knew the classical
Sufi literature which might explain why
he knew so well the story of bistami for
example
um so shem's was certainly a highly
educated man while he was from Tabriz
originally he seems to have early on
traveled all around the Islamic world
looking for a teacher that could sort of
match his own spiritual attainments and
and sort of prove himself worthy of
being his master which he could never
really find it seems yeah he seems to
spend a significant amount of time in
Damascus in Syria where he also met and
spent time with sufis you know Sufi
Masters and Mystics including a guy that
he refers to as Sheikh Muhammad
who might actually be the famous IBN
Arabi although it's not entirely certain
but it seems at least in my opinion it
seems pretty clear that he is referring
to IBN Arabi and he often praises and
and talks about these Masters in a very
sort of loving and appreciative way but
none of them could truly sort of match
him and live up to his high requirements
and expectations
that is of course until he arrives in
Konya and meets roomy who who sort of
makes all his dreams and and wishes come
true
they had a very close relationship for
the short time that Shams was in Konya
but all things weren't well indeed many
of Rumi's followers developed a strong
jealousy over the fact that Shams was
given such a high status basically
making Rumi neglect his public role as a
teacher and spending time with them
on top of this Shams appear to them to
be just some poor dervish without nearly
the scholarly prowess of their Master
how could he possibly deserve all this
praise and treatment
and many of the disciples seem to have
made these feelings known some accounts
even state that they might have shed up
threatened Champs with violence if he
didn't believe
whatever reason one day Shams is
suddenly gone
he had left cornea behind throwing Rumi
into complete despair he stopped
composing poetry he became an even more
reclusive person than before and was
generally just very distraught
his followers realized that things had
pretty much backfired instead of
bringing their Master back to them The
Disappearance of shems only made things
worse
eventually they got word that Shams had
gone to Damascus and Rumi sent his son
Sultan balad on a mission to retrieve
him which he did
shems once again returns to Konya things
are much better this time they celebrate
by holding Samar sessions and Rumi once
again composes poetry
but All Things Must Pass as they say and
only about a year later Shams disappears
once again but this time for good
Rumi sends several missions to find him
in Syria and other places but no one
could find a single trace of him
eventually Rumi had to give up and
realize that his son was gone and that
he now had to find that Light Within
himself instead of an inexternal person
his spiritual training was in a way
finally complete
there are many different accounts about
what happened to shem's one famous
example told in the in the chronicle of
afflecki for example states that the
followers of Rumi became jealous once
again and that this time they went so
far as to actually murder shems
um in some accounts it's even stated
that one of Rumi's own Sons Allah Adin
was a key figure in this plot to murder
shems another version however is less
dramatic
Shams seems to have expressed a desire
to leave shortly before disappearing
aspect of the Sufi path is when the
student has to leave the Sheikh or
Master behind and complete his training
on his own
in this case though Rumi couldn't really
leave because he had so many
responsibilities as a teacher in Konya
so Shams might have decided to instead
leave Rumi as the last part of his
teaching we really don't know what
happened to Shams some claim that he
went back to Tabriz and that he died
there a few years later there is
actually a claim or a place it's claimed
that he died in a place called hoi in
Iran and there's actually kind of
Mausoleum or a supposed burial place and
a tomb for Shams there on the other hand
there's also some that claim that sham's
body actually lies in cornea because you
know following this idea that he was
murdered it is said that that the the
murderers threw shemp's body into a well
in Konya and that his body is still
there there's I believe there's a kind
of even a kind of Monument where his
body might be so there are disagreements
about what happened to to Shams at the
end of the day we simply don't know it's
a mystery and we will probably never
know for sure
what we do know for sure though is the
incredible impact that Shams had on Rumi
from the time of shams's disappearance
in 1247 or 12 48 Lumi would sort of
really come into his own he would take
on this role as as the incredibly uh
powerful Mystic that he is known for
today
Shams had turned him from a mystically
oriented scholar to an ecstatic lover
he's following in Konya the
proto-mevlevies in other words grew to a
significant size and he would have he
had incredible power even on a kind of
semi-political level
it's also after this final disappearance
of Shams that Rumi composes the majority
of the Poetry that we all know and love
to The Wider World Rumi is of course
famous as one of the greatest love poets
in history and his verse is undeniably
magnificent
he was greatly influenced by earlier
Persians to be poets such as sana'i and
fariduddin atar the author of the famous
Conference of the birds indeed there is
even a famous story that Rumi met a Todd
as a young boy when he and his father
was traveling west from Balch but this
is most likely more of a legendary story
than historical fact in any case Roma's
literary output is very impressive not
only taking inspiration from these
earlier poets but also being very
original and unique himself
he truly had a remarkable skill at
conveying the sometimes complex
teachings of Islam and Sufism to a
general audience and his words are able
to touch people regardless of their
cultural or religious background this
was a very useful skill in Konya at the
time with a large non-muslim population
as well as recent converts with limited
knowledge of the religion even during
his own lifetime Rumi was not just
popular and renowned among his fellow
Muslims but also by Christians and Jews
living in the region at the time
in terms of his poetry there are two
major Works to consider
the first is his Devon or diwan that
we've already mentioned before going on
the titles like the Divani shems the
Divan of Shem satabrizi or the Divani
Kabir the great Devon
now a diwan or Devon in Persian isn't
necessarily A coherent work per se but
it's a full collection of poetry
in other words this is a work that
contains all or most of Rumi's
individual poems in various Styles and
forms
as the title suggests the work as a
whole is dedicated to shems and many
other poems either take on the poetic
Persona and voice of shems or are
dedicated to praising or talking about
this master often in an even
surprisingly devotional tone just listen
to this quote you are my sky I am the
Earth dumbfounded
but things you sprout from my heart each
moment
I am parched Earth rained down on me
drops of Grace for your water makes the
earth grow Rosy
what does the Earth know what you sow in
it you made it pregnant you know what it
Bears every Adam pregnant with your
Mysteries you make it writhe a while in
pangs of birth what Marvel survived to
birth through the world womb
and I am God the call Glory To Me
the Divine contains over 5 000 poems and
44 000 verses
about three thousand of them are
so-calleds a popular form of poetry in
Persian and another 2000 are rubayat or
quatrains
then there are also a few clasadas and
other poetic genres
the language also varies with the vast
majority of the poems of course being in
Persian but a few were in Arabic and
there are even some instances of Turkish
and Greek
needless to say this is an incredible
collection containing some of the most
famous lines of poetry in history
it deals with all kinds of topics but
some more Central themes such as for
example love
love is one of the key concepts for Rumi
and it isn't for nothing that he's seen
as such a great love poet
but this love is more complex than many
might imagine
primarily when Rumi talks about love
he's talking about love of God and the
love that exists between God and
creation a love that is the thread that
keeps the cosmos together and which
pulls the Mystic towards his God and to
where the essential Unity of reality
now that isn't to say that worldly love
such as love between spouses is
irrelevant to this poetry
poets like Rumi don't make a clear
distinction between metaphysical or
Divine love and human love It's All the
Same Love
human love becomes like a manifestation
or expression of the more Universal
Divine love that is at the core of his
message
so his poetry can often be read in
different ways and on different levels
of meaning all of which are often true
at the same time which is what makes his
poetry so accessible
but the second major poetic work and
probably the one that is the most
renowned worldwide is a more coherent
and unified one
it's an epic narrative poem called the
masnavi IMA Navi often known under the
shorter title the masnavi
the full title means something like
spiritual couplets the word masnavi
simply being the name of the particular
poetic style or form that it's written
in which is known as
in Arabic and this is essentially just
rhyming couplets
it's the same poetic form that Ataris
Conference of the birds was written in
among many other famous poems at the
time
but it goes to show just how influential
and loved Rumi's poem is that it is
universally known as the masnavi indeed
this work has been so celebrated in the
Muslim world to the point that has even
been called the Quran in Persian
and it is in some ways a commentary on
the Quran or on the general teachings of
Islam as understood through Rumi's
Sufism
it deals with all kinds of religious and
spiritual topics from law to Theology
and spiritual practice but through
accessible poetry in the form of stories
fables and many other fascinating and
entertaining yet of course profound
narratives and sections the masnavi was
composed sometime during the last 10 or
so years of roomy's life from around
1260 to 1273.
it was composed at the request of
roomies at the time senior disciple and
successor joseon Celebi who was also
present during the actual composing
itself
Rumi and her samadin would sit together
Rumi would recite the poetry and hosama
Deen would write it down and then would
read it back to him
for many years this process went on
which isn't surprising when you consider
the length of the work the masnavi
consists of six books with about 25
000 verses a truly epic poem and
possibly one of the greatest literary
achievements in history
but like we said Rumi was not just a
poet but also a famous and loved
preacher
and there are prose Works attributed to
him as well
particular there is a work entitled The
fihi mafihi which essentially means
something like in it what is in it and
this is a collection of sermons or
discourses of Rumi delivered to his
students and then written down
while not as famous as his poetry this
is still a very significant work and
features important details about his
teachings and biography in a more
straightforward prowse form
we can tell just from reading these
discourses even in Translation that he
must have been quite a compelling
speaker
but what are all those teachings that he
conveyed in his poetry what is the
philosophy of Rumi the teachings and
wisdoms that we find and works like the
Devon or the masnavi and which have
captivated so many people worldwide
in many ways Rumi represents a certain
flavor of Sufism that emphasizes a
particular concept that of love
we already talked about this a bit
earlier but love is indeed one of the
most recurring and important themes in
the poetry and the practice of Islam
that he represents this love as we saw
is both on a practical mystical and even
metaphysical level
he was a Sufi and so his focus is on
many of those common and familiar Sufi
themes that we have explored in earlier
episodes
the Sufi path is one of ascending
stations where you are Guided by a
Sheikh or Master on gradually higher
levels of intimacy with God
eventually on the highest level the
Mystic reaches what is known as
annihilation in God where the person
becomes completely effaced in the
reality of the Divine and experiences
the true Oneness of reality or of God
this is what is sought by the Sufi and
is described in so many of the poems
quote you are your own shadow become
annihilated in the Rays of the Sun how
long will you look at your shadow look
also at his light
or quote the world is snow and ice and
thou art the burning summer no trace of
it remains O King when thy traces appear
the realization of this Oneness and a
direct experience of God is essentially
hindered by a single thing
the Neffs often translated as ego or
self
it is our idea and attachment to the
idea of a separate individual self and
on the cravings and wants that results
from that self that keeps us from
Experiencing God and of uniting with God
or rather of realizing that essential
Oneness that is there all along
this idea of the nafs and the path to
fight against and annihilate it is a key
theme in Rumi he even identifies the
nafs with Iblis or the devil and even
with hell itself in his discourses Rumi
explains it like this quote
with God there is no room for two egos
you say I and he says I
in order for this Duality to disappear
either you must die for him or he for
you it is not possible however for him
to die either phenomenally or
conceptually because he is the ever
living who dieth not
he is so gracious however that if it
were possible he would die for you in
order that The Duality might disappear
since it is not possible for him to die
you must die but he may be manifested to
you thus eliminating The Duality
the whole process of the Sufi path the
fasting Retreats renunciation evicted
and listening to music is to transcend
this cell for ego the nephs over the
course of the spiritual journey the
nephs is gradually burnt away until
nothing of it remains and only then can
God appear
True selfhood Lies in the experience of
no self of being nothing at all as he
said in the realm of the Divine in the
realm of unity there can be no Duality
no you and I but only the
all-encompassing reality of the Divine
room himself refers to this burning of
the self when he says quote three short
phrases tell the story of my life I was
raw I got cooked I burned
speaking about this transcending of
Duality he also says quote from the
beginning when I heard the story of
being in love I wore up my soul heart
and eyes in its path
I said perhaps the lover and beloved are
too
but both were one and I was seeing
double
according to the Quran and Islamic
theology we were once United in
pre-existence before God's
existentiating command after which
multiplicity and the phenomenal World
appeared thus we have become separated
from God snatched away from that
original state of unity which is the
cause of all our suffering or rather it
is our ideas and attachment to the false
idea of an independent self that causes
trouble
and once we're able to transcend that
self to forget it completely we can find
the essential Oneness hiding underneath
it is precisely this theme that Rumi
talks about in the opening lines to the
massive masnabi a section that has
become famous in its own right as the
song of the read and could be argued to
be the most famous section of Persian
poetry in history
in these couplets Rumi uses the image of
the Nave flute a popular instrument in
the Middle East and Central Asia and its
sorrowful wailing tones as a mirroring
of the human Cry of Longing To Be United
once again with God
just as the knave fluid longs to return
to the Reed bed from which it came the
human longed to return to Unity
to give you an idea of the beauty of
this poetry I think it's worthwhile to
hear it in its original Persians that we
can experience the melody and rhyming
the masnavi and the Poetry of Rumi in
general is very musical in nature which
really comes through in the original
language so here are the first 18 lines
of the masnavi also known as the song of
the Reed read by Safa mirror with
accompanying translation
foreign
[Music]
Kitty
Harris
foreign
[Music]
a truly remarkable piece of literature
that manages to encapsulate so many of
the aspects of Sufi teachings and and
particularly the teachings of Rumi in a
few short lines
um just as the Nay is hollow on the
inside to allow for the breadth of the
player to to course through it so the
individual person must empty himself and
become Hollow on the inside become
nothing become empty become nothing so
that the Breath of God in this metaphor
the love of God can sort of course
through the person and create music
equally as beautiful as the music of the
Nay it's really amazing imagery
Safar actually has a YouTube channel
where she among other things does
beautiful readings of Persian poetry and
I believe she's just about to do a
series on the song of the read in
particular so if you're interested in
that kind of stuff you should check out
that channel and I will leave links to
that in the description
in the last 18th cuplet Ruby says that
quote words must be cut short and this
is another important aspect of his
thoughts and that of Sufism in general
this knowledge and experience of God
Rumi is describing and the Mystic seeks
is not a knowledge that can be put into
words or understood through Concepts
in this sense Rumi isn't interested in
philosophy or the wisdoms that can be
learned through books that kind of
knowledge that is conceptual knowledge
often known as in Arabic and also in
Persian is severely limited and can
never give us true knowledge of God
instead the can of knowledge a Mystic
like a Rumi seeks is something else
it's something often called madifa in
the tradition which is sometimes
translated as Gnostic knowledge or
mystical knowledge this is not knowledge
learned through words but intuited or
directly experienced through what's
known as cash for literally unveiling
the veils of Illusion of independent
self and all that's acquired
quote-unquote knowledge are ripped away
to where nothing remains and in that
darkness of annihilation one directly
experiences the truth of Oneness a truth
completely beyond words or concepts
quotes oh Union with thee is the root of
all choice for these are all forms but
that is meaning
or in the classic poem quote I am not me
you are not you and you are not me
yet I am me you are you and you are me
as well
with you I am such that I am in doubt
whether I am you or you are me
in the Sufi tradition another word is
used to describe this kind of intuitive
knowledge which is Valk and this
literally in Arabic means tasting this
is a really great word because it's sort
of
um it sort of captures uh the way that
we can think of this kind of knowledge
so just as you can never truly know what
something tastes like say in another
video I took the example of a piece of
chocolate someone can describe chocolate
to you or you know
fall day you will never know truly what
chocolate tastes like until you just put
it in your mouth and taste it for
yourself and this is what manifa or this
kind of mystical knowledge is like you
can never truly have this knowledge
without experiencing it yourself this is
that that is the whole point
and that central theme of Love
um and love as knowledge is another
great metaphor for this because just as
this knowledge this knowledge of God is
is something that cannot be described or
really put into words so when we when
we're in love when we feel love love is
is this kind of feeling this this uh
this way of of being that
no one can really truly put into words
right it's an experience that is beyond
expression and in human language in some
way but we all know love when we feel it
it's this obvious feeling that we all
have but it's really difficult to put
into words
so that's why this idea of Love also as
long along with support like tasting
love is a really great metaphor uh and
sort of a symbol for this kind of uh
mystical knowledge it is love that burns
away the nephs the self and there is
love that gives us this true knowledge
which is identical to that love in a
certain sense quote The Lover's
sufferings like no other suffering love
is the astrolabe of God's Own Mysteries
no matter whether love is of this world
or of the next it steals us to that
world
whatever words I say to explain this
love
when I arrive at love I am ashamed
though language gives a clear account of
love it love beyond all language is the
clearer
the pen had gone at Breakneck speed in
writing but when it came to love it
split into
the explaining mind sleeps like an ass
in mud for Love Alone explains love and
the lover
love forumi also extends outward
to love God is to love God's creation
love your fellow human beings animals
and even plants Rumi is described in the
biographies as a remarkably kind and
loving person and to basically everyone
we even find Shams being a little
concerned about just how nice Rumi was
to everyone but this was part of his
essential world view
when we read his works the Rumi comes
across as a very there's a tolerant
understanding and open-minded person
even towards those of other Creeds
within Islam and even other religions
altogether
quote if you have lost heart in the path
of Love flee to me without delay I am a
fortress invincible
this also needs to be significantly
nuanced we have to remember that Rumi
was a devout Muslim he performed all the
practices expected of a Muslim such as
the prayers and the fasting Etc and he
time and time again emphasizes the
importance of doing these things and of
following the Islamic law as we saw he
was himself an expert and Authority on
hanafi law so this is hardly surprising
even after he became an intoxicated
loving Mystic he was still an expert on
Islamic law he would still give out
fatwas or legal opinions people would
come to him for for answers to to
questions relating to Islamic law and
belief for sure he saw Islam as the only
fully True Religion the Quran as the
last Revelation to Mankind and Muhammad
as the final prophet
he also followed Sunni Islam in
particular and wrote critically about
shiism in some places in other words
Rumi was Muslim there is really no
denying or even debating this question
today he has often been construed as
some Universalist Mystic where religious
adherence isn't important this is simply
a complete misrepresentation and
oversimplification of his person and
teachings and is often supported by the
many fake roomy quotes that are spread
out all over the internet
Rumi saw himself as a Muslim and Islam
was to him the one true religion to be
followed
with that said however there is also no
denying that he was what many today
would refer to as tolerance of religious
differences he had a certain ecumenical
approach to such questions and seems to
have stayed away from sectarianism as
much as possible
this stems partly from Rumi's strong
insistence on the inner spiritual
meanings and Truths Behind all religious
observances the so-called Mana
he often criticizes other Muslims for
getting too bogged down in the
formalities and observances of rituals
while forgetting or neglecting their
inner meanings which are the true
purpose of religion outward practices
are like a shell and the inner meanings
are the core he uses a famous example
here about the elephant standing in a
dark room an analogy that seems to come
from India originally multiple people
enter this dark room to figure out what
the object is one person touches the leg
and says it's something like a tree
another one grabs the trunk and says it
like a snake a third one the stomach and
says it's like a brick wall for instance
all of the men are describing the same
object but their limited perspectives
mean that they also get a just a portion
of the whole truth thus their conception
is somewhat distorted and colored by
that particular perspective
similarly there is one truth of religion
which many different Traditions describe
in various ways none of whom can fully
see the elephant for what it is but
still describe it through their
particular perspective in some ways each
person has their own way to God and
there's the intention and inner state of
the worshiper that is most important
without of course neglecting the outward
aspect quote
for hindis Hindi is for Praise of God
the praise of God in Sindhi is for
cindies I am not Sanctified by their
laudations it's they who are made holy
stewing pearls we look at neither
languages nor words but at the soul and
at the inner state
inspecting Hearts we see if they are
humble although the spoken words are not
so humble
one of the best examples of this idea is
in another story from the masnabi about
Moses and the shepherd which this
earlier quote is a section from in this
story Moses is walking along and sees a
Shepherd in deep prayer and worship but
he worships in a unique way quote
O Lord my God where are you that I may
become your servant that I may sue your
shoes and comb your hair that I may wash
your clothes and kill your lies and
bring your milk to you your eminence
talking about God and such
anthropomorphic ways is of course
unacceptable to Moses who harshly scolds
the shepherd for his behavior quote
you've sunk a long way down no muslim
you you've turned into a heathen what
Pitfall is this what blasphemy and Guff
Go stuff some cotton wool into your
mouth
the shepherd is ashamed he apologizes
and disappears into the desert
but at this point God speaks to Moses
and explains that is he who has acted
unjustly
although the prayers of the shepherd
were flawed because of anthropomorphism
by scolding him Moses had only taken him
further away from God creating
separation instead of Union Court
you have repelled from us our loyal
servant
did you come to create a sense of union
or did you come to generate division
do not touch separation if you can for
me the worst of all things is divorce
I have consigned a way for everyone to
everyone a different idiom for him it's
praise for you disparagement for him
it's honey for you it's poison
love of God with flawed outer practice
is better than no worship or love at all
Moses is ashamed and returns to the
shepherd who turns out to be actually
doing great Having learned from The
Experience becoming inspired in his
despair to go beyond all these dualities
and find Annihilation himself
this story really encapsulates the
central aspect of Rumi's teaching that
it is love that is at the center of
worship and of reality it is love and
the state of the heart that binds the
human to God and it is through love that
we reach the Divine a love that is
all-encompassing
loving worship of God even comes before
outer ritual practices
it is the goal that is prioritized not
the way there Rumi unlike many others in
his day isn't focused on the formalities
of the law but on the state of the soul
and the Heart it is this that truly
matters
in some ways love even transcends
religion and religious laws
we shouldn't misunderstand this to mean
a rejection of the religious law but
rather that love is universal and in a
state of complete loving absorption in
God and in Union One transcends all
multiplicity including religious
divisions quotes
the faith of Love is separate from all
others for lovers faith and piety are
God
there are many religions and spiritual
paths in the world and Islam is the one
that will fully lead to Salvation
according to Rumi but for most the goal
is the same God
every saint befriend and Prophet has a
path but all the paths that lead to God
are one
or quote Beyond kufur and Islam there is
a desert plane
in that middle space are passions reign
when the Gnostic arrives there he'll
prostrate himself not quiver not Islam
nor is there any space in that domain
ultimately the world is a Unity truth is
one regardless of sectarian divisions it
is human words and Concepts that create
Division and conflict quote division in
mankind is born of names when names
reach meaning there is harmony
in such statements we can clearly see
someone who is disinterested in
sectarian divisions although he was a
Sunni Muslim and was devoted to that
particular path he also seems to state
that Beyond such outer conflicts and
divisions there is a singular truth the
truth of love and unity Rumi calls on
the listeners to come to that place of
Love regardless of who they are
in one of the most famous and often
quoted poems called Come Again Come
Again whatever you are come again if
you're a Catholic or Idol worshiper come
again
this home of ours is Not A Home of
hopelessness even if you repented a
hundred times come again
in relation to some of these ideas many
have connected the thought of Rumi with
that of his famous older contemporary
IBN Arabi and his Doctrine which later
became known as
the unity of being
as we saw it's quite likely that Rumi
knew of a banana be and that he might
have even met him when he lived in
Damascus Romy was also friends we had
then lived in the same city as IBN
arabi's Chief disciple sadradeen kunawi
but as Scholars like William chiddick
had convincingly argued there is little
reason to think that IBN arabi's ideas
had any direct influence on Rumi
although there are similarities there
are also many significant differences as
Rumi's writings lack many of the
characteristic teachings and vocabulary
of the school of even Arabi in terms of
his metaphysics and philosophy another
one of the most Central key themes for
Rumi is the distinction he draws between
form Surah and meaning Mana the world
that we experience the world of
Multiplicity is a kind of Illusion it's
a dream a veil of reality through forms
that hide the meanings behind it
most people only see the forms of the
world the surface level foam on the
Ocean or the dust and the wind and they
never realize that all these forms are
pointing to the hidden realities or
reality behind it all
they are the outer manifestation of that
hidden meaning
William chiddick explains quote
ultimately meaning is that thing as it
is known to God himself and since God is
beyond any sort of Multiplicity in the
last analysis the meaning of all things
is God
in other words behind the illusion and
veil of Multiplicity there is a Unity or
Oneness namely God the world as we know
it is according to Rumi like a shadow
but this isn't gnosticism Rumi is not a
complete denier of the physical world as
we've seen all of reality is pervaded by
kind of Oneness or Unity the forms are
the manifestations of the meaning it is
only our misunderstanding that creates
trouble chidic again says quad form and
meaning are inextricably connected form
derives from meaning and meaning
manifests itself as form
since the two are the outward and inward
aspects of a single reality each is
important in its own way
but for most people the danger lies in
giving too much importance to form and
not understanding that it derives its
existence and significance from meaning
and this is where you find some of those
similarities between Rumi and thinkers
like even Arabi that the two seemingly
hold what many would perceive as a kind
of monistic worldview just like for IBN
Arabi Rumi seems to imply that
ultimately there is only God and that
all other things are a kind of Illusion
at the core of reality is a Unity or
Oneness hiding beneath the multiplicity
of apparent existence or form this kind
of idea can be found all over Ruby's
works for example in the very opening
section of the masnabi which says quote
the lover is a veil all is beloved
beloved lives the lover is a corpse
or in the Divine where he says quote my
soul and yours have been essentially won
as well as my appearance and yours and
my hiddenness and yours
only for the sake of others
understanding that I say mine and yours
since in reality there is no me and you
in my interior and yours
we must be careful to not interpret
these ideas as crude pantheism though
there is always a clear distinction
between God and Creation in a sense and
rumor just like his fellow sufis are
always very careful to not say that God
is ever incarnated in the human being in
any way or that the that it is a
situation where the two Essences become
one the human and and God so to say he
makes this clear in one of the core
trains from the Divine quote
as long as the servant of God does not
become absolutely extinguished of self
the unity of God does not become
verified by him
Unity is not The Descent of God into you
it is you not being
for something false does not become true
merely by Idol boasting
or in another quadrant quote anyone who
ties something untied into a knot laughs
at his own condition and the condition
of the world they speak words about
Union and separation yet how can
something that was never separated be
joined
but there's no denying as is clear from
these same verses that there are many
indications in Rumi's writings pointing
to what we can semi-problematically
refer to as a kind of monism
it doesn't help that many of the most
major commentaries of the masnavi were
done from the perspective of IBN Arabi
School further of course solidifying
that kind of interpretation of the poems
but the rumor was his own person with
unique ideas that he inherited from his
Iranian form of Sufism but there are
clearly many parallels here too
known widely as mawlana Rumi passed away
in 1273 at just over 65 years old
his funeral was attended by scores of
people in the city not only fellow
Muslims but Christians and Jews young
and old poor people and the political
leaders all of whom mourn the loss of a
saint and spiritual giant that impacted
just about everyone
the funeral prayers were led by another
major Sufi figure Southern konawi and
eventually a major Shrine was erected on
the site of romy's burial which still
stands today as a centerpiece of the
city of Konya clearly by the time he
died Rumi was already a major figure in
various respects and he left behind a
legacy of both students and devoted
admirers but also the massive output of
poetry that we've already mentioned
poetry that would still be read and
admired around the world 800 years later
even to this day the anniversary of his
death what is known as the Chevy aruz
which means the wedding night is
celebrated every year with a lot of
people coming to Kanya to the shrine of
Rumi to celebrate and and do listen to
samah and all these kinds of things
um
in Sufism so to explain this this
concept of the wedding night in Sufism
it is thought that at death when someone
dies they are reunited with God so death
is seen as something very positive it is
is like again like the name suggests
like a wedding night the orus it is
often called when someone dies it's that
someone returns to God and is united
with God just like a bride and
bridegroom would be United at their
wedding so every year
um the death of Rumi is celebrated and
and he is remembered on this day which
since the Gregorian calendar was um was
implemented is celebrated I believe on
December 17th every year and and the
center of these celebrations are of
course in Konya even today the
significant group of followers and
students that he had established his
school of Sufism so to say was first led
by hosama Dean the aforementioned
disciples Central to the composition of
the masnavi but eventually leadership of
the Brotherhood went to Rumi's son
Sultan valad who would become a key
figure in the development of his
father's Community into a proper Sufi
order
wrote several important Works himself
including poetry but it must have been
hard to follow someone like Rumi and
with that responsibility imagine having
imagine having Rumi as your father and
then trying to pursue poetry
like seems like a lot of pressure in any
case it is in these succeeding years and
decades after mawlana's death that we
see the development of the nevlevy Sufi
order based on Rumi's teachings and
lineage which is today famous around the
world and has been one of the most
influential Sufi orders in history the
maplevy order is very much based on the
personality teachings and practices of
Rumi it emphasizes love as a key driving
force and takes an approach to Sufism
that is decidedly what we often call
intoxicated or ecstatic
Rumi's poetry was and remains an
important component of the being recited
regularly during ritual events and
Gatherings furthermore Rumi's great love
for music and Sama that spiritual
concert that we talked about developed
into a staple and Cornerstone of the
meblovic tradition
the way that Rumi and his disciples
would perform the Sama with a whirling
or spinning kind of dance or motion
became an elaborate and highly
ritualized practice in later centuries
and is today famous as the so-called
whirling dervishes
the dervous world in emotion that
reflects the Motions of the planets the
uh the spinning motion which is a
central motion of the entire universe
and reality one arm extended upwards and
the other stretched outward to the side
representing a kind of reception and
transmission receiving the Divine love
and spreading it upwardly around you
this is at least one among many
interpretations of the symbolism at play
here and on top of this the medley order
also of course involved more standard
aspects of Sufi practice such as thicker
for instance particularly a form of
Dicker where the name Allah is chanted
over and over again as well as things
like Retreats fasting and other such
techniques the maplevy order eventually
became one of the most if not the most
powerful and popular Sufi order in the
Ottoman Empire indeed the order and its
sheikhs and leaders often had close
contact with the ottoman Sultans who
would sponsor the building of medley
buildings and lodges
for example the famous ottoman Sultan
Suleiman the Magnificent was involved
with the building of the Sama Hall in
the great Melody complex in Konya the
meblovir together with the nakshbandiya
were often seen as more Orthodox Sufi
orders that adhere to the principles of
Islamic law whereas other orders in the
region were looked at with more
suspicion by the states such as the big
Tashi order for example whose status
kind of wavered and varied with the
times
but despite this great popularity and
the general Fame of Rumi as a poet and
the spiritual Master around the Islamic
world the medley order has remained
mostly based in Anatolia there have been
significant communities in Damascus
Jerusalem and Tripoli and Lebanon but
the majority of medley activities have
taken place in the heartlands of the
Ottoman Empire this status as a more
Orthodox Sufi order wasn't always
obvious though as there have often been
individuals and ships that have taken a
more anti-nominant path The Scholar
Ahmed Kara Mustafa argues in his book
God's unruly friends that there has
always existed two strands or attitudes
within the meblibi community
one that more closely adheres to the
rules of the Sharia and the expectations
of Muslim piety and behavior the
mainstream in other words and another
that is more anti-nominant than leaning
towards malamati or kalandari Sufism
the malamatis which literally means the
people of blame or the blameworthy is a
certain strand or attitude within Sufism
where one's inner spiritual state is
hidden from the outside world sometimes
by acting in questionable ways that
breaks social norms the kalandariya
often represents the most extreme form
of this tendency with individuals that
would consciously break all kinds of
laws and Norms they would drink alcohol
urinate in public they would shave off
all their hair including beard and
eyebrows and often they would wander
around singing and dancing all this had
a spiritual purpose it was a way of
fighting the ego or itself in the most
extreme Way by literally making other
people despise you for your behavior a
really fascinating group of Mystics
and there have been certain nebulavis in
history sometimes even prominent leader
figures that have leaned towards these
kinds of movements and attitudes with
that said the majority of mevelis and
their General reputation has been quite
the opposite
after the death of Rumi the highest
leadership of the order was carried on
by his descendants
the first one was his son Sultan balad
as we saw but this line has continued
until this very day the leaders of the
maplevy order were given the title
chalabi and that is the chalabi that has
the highest Authority being able to
decide who is an official Sheikh or
Master within the order the current
leader of the memories is Farooq hamdam
chalabi
with that said the organizational
structure of the melevies have altered
significantly during the last century or
so even to some degree sort of falling
apart in some ways
um while the memories as we said had a
pretty good standing and a relationship
with the ottoman Sultans during the
Ottoman Empire this would significantly
change in the 20th century when the
Ottoman Empire fell apart and the
Republic of Turkey was formed there was
a new attitude towards religion
turkey was to become a secular State and
there were many different processes that
that were set in motion to make turkey
secular and Sufism in this new in this
new um
in this new turkey was seen as old
Superstition these Sufi orders had way
too much power and so in 1925 Sufism and
all its activities were officially
forbidden in Turkey so all the melody
lodges were closed down they were
forbidden from performing their classic
rituals like Sama and zikr and this
Still Remains the rule to this day this
has had a significant impact on the
order in the modern world for obvious
reasons
um like the the Sama ritual for instance
which has been such a central part of of
the order can be experienced today by
tourists but this is mostly because it
has been constructed or it's it's
painted as a cultural heritage right a
cultural practice and not a religious
ritual this is why it has been allowed
to continue in some fashion in Turkey
today and can be experienced again for
example by by tourists but the actual
practices and and the map of your order
as such has altered significantly and
the hierarchical structure and the
organizational structure of the order
has
compared to earlier kind of Fallen apart
but the legacy of jalala din Rumi and
the melevies live on around the world in
different ways official sheikhs
recognized by the Celebi such as Kabir
helminski in the U.S keep the order
alive and of course it is the Poetry of
Romeo that has taken the World by storm
books of translation of Rumi's poems
sell in numbers that other modern poets
could only dream of it really is an
amazing development
but like we mentioned earlier many of
these popular translations often greatly
alter the original meaning and flavor of
Rumi's works
in particular the Islamic character of
The Poetry is often removed completely
they can be read and enjoyed as poetry
on its own but not necessarily as always
representing the thoughts and words of
Rumi himself on top of this there is
also a whole ocean of fake roomy quotes
out there I would say that a lot of if
not maybe even the majority of those
famous quotes by Roman that we see on
Instagram or Twitter and all these other
sites are either outright fake like not
being by Rumi at all or they have been
significantly altered in their
translation so that most people in the
west especially have a kind of skewed
image of Rumi and his actual teachings
for more quote unquote accurate
translations that stick more closely to
the original Persian meanings we have to
turn elsewhere
there are many different translations of
Rumi out there and it can be hard to
navigate where to turn and who to trust
if you want scholarly translations of
his poetry there are actually some great
options out there when it comes to the
masnavi I would especially recommend the
works of Nicholson
and Alan Williams
uh the only like actual full translation
of all the six books of of Rumi actually
at least like a scholarly translation or
those by Reynold a Nicholson which was
written I think was finished in 1940 or
at least in the 1940s
um this still holds up it's a good
translation although it it does it's
kind of a dry
translation it has this sort of all
style of language and it can be a little
dry although it sticks pretty closely to
the original meanings
um if that's what you're after
uh there's also a more recent
translation by Jawad mojadadi which is a
beautiful poetic translation so much has
actually tried to mimic the rhyming and
Melody of the original Persian and a
really beautiful way so it's a really
aesthetically pleasing translation to
read although because of this
methodology he has of course been forced
to make some creative
um taking some creative Liberties in
order to make them rhyme and work in
this way but still I would highly
recommend this translation it is
accurate and it's really beautiful to
read at the moment of recording this
mojadity has only only released the
first five books out of six but
hopefully the the last one should be
coming out in the in the coming years
and then lastly the most recently
started translation project of the
masnavi is that by Alan Williams which
is also highly recommended and really
really beautiful it does not have it
does not take the uh poetic rhyming
approach of modernity instead sticking
closer to the original Persian and the
the word for word meanings but still
being very aesthetically pleasing and
beautiful to read so those when it comes
to the masnavi those are the
translations that I would recommend
um Alan Williams's translation is only
so far put out the first two books out
of six that are still still also sort of
work in progress but
um
very much looking forward to the rest of
those coming out and for now you can
enjoy the first two books
um maybe that's a good thing so you can
sort of get a get a slow start take one
thing at a time because it is a it is a
long work as for room is Devon or
collection of poems the Divani Shams
things are more complicated there is no
full translation of the entire Divan
into English but there are a few
um selections uh
nice sizable representations of some of
the poems the quadrants of Rumi by
Ibrahim gamard and rawan farhadi is a
translation of all the quadrants or
rubayat from the Devon in particular and
it's highly recommended
for a selection of the results you can
consult author John arbury's Works
particularly the two volume collection
mystical poems of Rumi which include 400
of the ghazals from the divan
as for the prose Works in particular his
discourses
areberry has also published a
translation of this work under the title
discourses of Rumi
there is also a more recent and very
competent translation of the same work
by W.M Thaxton which is called science
of the Unseen the discourses of Rumi
so now you have a place to start so you
can hopefully two start to explore the
wonderful masterpieces that are the many
poems and and works of jaladin Rumi
we've seen that his life is a
fascinating tale of love war conflict
and heartbreak living through one of the
most eventful periods in the history of
the Middle East
we've explored the different aspects of
his life that would have inspired and
been a catalyst for his poetry and
gotten to know him and those around him
a little closer
hopefully this allows us to appreciate
even more the absolutely awe-inspiring
poetry that he has become so famous for
The masnabi Remains one of the most
famous and revered works of literature
in history even as we saw being called
the Quran in Persian and being
appreciated by people from various
backgrounds and spiritual leanings
Rumi left behind a legacy not just of
poetry but as a beacon of spiritual
light in the world one of the great
Mystics and luminaries in world history
was beloved by Muslims as well as
Christians and Jews for his openness and
understanding His Kind nature and the
way that he was able to speak to the
Common Man and convey the most lofty
spiritual ideals
it is therefore not surprising that he's
just as relevant today as he has ever
been and that his poems and different
forms Reach people on different
continents and over a time span of
almost a millennium through him the
Wailing lament of the Nay can still be
heard around the world
I'll see you next time
[Music]